aucune femme dans les 15 personnalités
préférées des français
les objets ne sont pas des femmes
linverse non plus des chiffres des
slogans des visuels chocs dans le cadre
de son temps des femmes
la ville de guyancourt se pose la
question l'égalité où en est on l'idée
étant de réunir des artistes autour de
cette thématique là de l'égalité avec
l'envi en tout cas de montrer les divers
supports du dic du discours féministe
aujourd'hui que ce soit du street art
comme avec les oeuvres de mystique qui
sont juste derrière moi on va voir aussi
de la vidéo de la fiche de
l'illustration aussi du dessin de presse
à d'autres si toutes les formes que
prend on peut prendre le discours autour
l'égalité aujourd'hui une dizaine
d'artistes ont répondu à l'appel parmi
eux arnaud corbin il interpelle le
public avec des chiffres chocs sur des
visuels
je milite et je m'engage pour que pour
que le monde qui nous entoure et put les
gens avec qui on travaille plus que soi
même on essaye d'être respectueux et de
vivre dans un monde un tout petit peu
plus tranquille tout petit peu plus
harmonieux un tout petit peu plus
respectueux l'exposition soyons affiché
est au centre de ce mois consacré aux
femmes et entraîne avec elle de
nombreuses animations pour toucher un
public le plus large possible
on a aussi des débats on a aussi au
théâtre notre ferme de bel ébat notre
centre culturel il ya aussi des
représentations théâtrales et on a aussi
une forte chaque année une forte
sensibilisation envers les enfants et
les plus jeunes et il ya plus de 300
jeunes qui se sont inscrits revenir avec
laurent enseignants visiter l'exposition
et puis aussi travailler et c'est ça qui
est le plus important
travailler sur le sujet de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
depuis le 1er janvier 2019 16 femmes
sont décédées sous les coups de leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint en france